willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
es um den begriff des ekels geht und
zwar bei seite und muss baum das sind
zwei lenker und denker die relativ jung
noch sind also die zwanzigste
jahrhundert gelebt haben auch leben
allerdings warm ist und das ist also der
plan des ganzen seminares in der letzten
sitzung hatten wir bei max scheler die
emotionen des kranes behandelt jetzt
steht heute am 26
15 gipfel im zentrum in der nächsten
sitzung kurzer blick steht die
verzweiflung als immer zu einem zentrum
basiert ihr gekommen
darauf dann die angst auch bei kick
gegeben auch der heilige vielleicht auch
noch bei anderen denkerinnen und denkt
dann muss ich noch schauen dann kommt
der neid und die eifersucht da ging ein
bisschen die artikel dann kommt ihr hass
hier habe ich heute auch noch was
interessantes als seite gefunden zudem
hast also wahrscheinlich wird der sound
ein bisschen ins spiel kommt und gegen
ende dieses semesters werden uns der
liebe zu wenden bei augustinus und eine
haben und auch bei harry friend wird
einen auch noch lebenden us
amerikanischen denke das ist der plan
des seminars hier noch mal kurz eine
abbildung des denkers der letzten
sitzung sie an es wäre es ist und es ist
max scheler und jetzt gibt es hier noch
ein schönes porträt
vielleicht wissen sie von wem dieses
porträts das ist diese typische stil von
otto dix der in diesen 20 jahren sehr
viele berühmte persönlichkeit der
damaligen zeit des kreis des lebens
porträtiert hat sehr realistisch
natürlich so das ist also die sitzung
gewesen ich geben kurzen rückblick auf
max regers bittet der schüler war ein
deutscher fan und googeln und er wendet
sich gegen eine naturalistische rettung
zionistische auffassung des ekels aber
auch der schaden vor allem ecke steht
man auch im zentrum schadens scheler
nichts versetzten
mit unserem körper zu tun hat oder mit
eigentlichen natürlichen eigenschaften
unseren charme hat auch was eine art von
geistige dimension charme ist ihr sagt
ein selbstgefühl in welchem sich der
mensch auf sich selbst bezieht man sich
erkennt also das mit selbsterkenntnis zu
tun
und das wiederum bedeutet dass sich
hierbei um eine nur eine kognitive
dimension handelt haben resultiert nach
china aus der spannung von anita
individualität und reflektierte
allgemeinheit bzw objektivität also wir
beziehen uns auf uns selbst in der scham
und erkennen uns in einer situation die
uns umgeben ist jetzt ist aber nicht nur
eine unangenehme situation sondern es
ist das erkennen als solches als
individuum was ich in einem verhältnis
zur allgemeinheit die die scham
generiert schwerer sagt auch sehr
treffen dass die scham ein schutz gefühl
des individuums gegen das allgemeine ist
das allgemeine ist wie er sagt zum
beispiel eine zeitung eine tageszeitung
in der wir auch nicht gerne vor kämen
wenn in dieser zeitung etwas ganz
individuelles von uns dargestellt
sicherlich kommen wir gern der zeitung
wenn die gelobt werden wenn wir eine
große leistung verbracht hat aber wenn
wir als individuen an einer diesen
eigenschaften die uns als individuum aus
nach vor aller augen stehen das ist die
allgemeinheit dafür gleich das mit einer
zeitung dann ist das uns peinlich oder
mehr noch wir stellen
ich finde dass er das sehr treffend
charakterisiert hat wir können uns das
jetzt auch ein phänomen was spieler
berücksichtigt wir können es auch für
andere schämen heutzutage sprechen wir
von fremdschämen
wir kennen das alles wenn wir uns eine
fernsehsendung anschauen eine talkshow
und da benimmt sich jemand was
eigentlich kann schlag wenn die hände
und das gesicht was eine typische
reaktion auch für die schampus und
schämt und selbst ihr fühlen das
mitglied charme
betrieben scham ist außerdem nach
schneller immer auf einen sachverhalt
bezogen als eine position die tatsache
dass es so ist und besitz des in eine
kognitive dimension also wir haben in
der scham über einen hohen grad von
bewusstheit mann und das leben passt
auch zu diesem selbstgefühl in welchem
sich der mensch auf sich selbst bezieht
und erkennt denken sie an die genesis in
der bibel wo adam und eva erkennt dass
sie nackt sind an und dann auf sich
nehmen und ihre nacktheit über münchen
wollen indem sie sich dann ein blatt vor
die scham halten
also das ist dieser punkt und schüler
sagt ganz am ende noch in seinem text
dass die scham in einem gewissen
verhältnis an engem verhältnis zum ekel
und zur angst stieg
er hat auch noch andere schöne ist schön
vergleich die schreiben ist wie ein als
mit der vorschrift wochen mir ein kleid
was unseren körper umhüllt eine art
schutz kleiner schutz gegenüber der
allgemeinheit
das fand ich auch noch sehr treffend ich
nach oben rechts danach ein youtube den
link zur letzten sitzung hinein
jetzt soll ist aber noch ein anderes
video gehen nämlich um das video über
phänomenologie also wer von ihnen sich
der technologie interessiert sagte schon
schiller ist ein phänomen lokale den wir
heute behandelt werden
dem sei dieses video auch das herz
klingt macht wieder oben rechts ein link
zu diesem video das interview es
überwindung nur die so die heutigen
leitfragen sind inwiefern handelt es
sich beim diplom eine emotion
wir haben in den vergangenen sitzungen
genauer definiert was an emotion ist ich
sage nochmal kurz nach diesem stanfour
und enzyklopädie philosophie artikel den
ich auch um dem video nachher für linke
ist an emotionen ein phänomen was eine
gefühls aspekt hat also zumindest ein
schmerz angenehm unangenehm
solche gefühls qualitäten dann hat es
aber auch eine kognitive dimension das
heißt es geht um einen objektiven
sachverhalt und es hat auch noch ein
emotionaler county nationale dimension
des heißen emotionen bewegt uns zu
lassen und eine gewisse energie die uns
antreibt zu irgendwann fast in der
charme wäre diese multinationale kraft
das für ihn dass sich zurückziehen dass
das ich verbergen wollen das wäre das
motiv was im rat enthalten es so also
neben jetzt geht es an den iran liefern
ist igel jetzt ein emotionen mit diesen
drei dimensionen man könnte doch sagen
ekel ist etwas was eintritt wenn ich
irgendwie ein stück vergammeltes fleisch
sehen in dem sich maden winden ja oder
anderes sagt wenn ich jetzt hier ein
stück fleisch besser und sie plötzlich
eine made die segnung bewegt zur dann
tritt dr idee auf warum sollte jetzt da
eine kognitive die mission
im spiel sein könnte man sich doch
fragen das ist doch ganz klein ein
reflex oder ein effekt sowie der
würgereflex so ist auch ekel endloser
reflexen ein effekt warum ist also eine
ideologie können wie riekel so verstehen
dass er eben nicht nur körper nicht
begriffen werden muss anders gefragt und
nicht an finden sich in ekel eine
urteils eine motivation ist eine gefühls
team zwei wie manifestiert sich der ist
phänomenal in der charme hatten wir
gesehen dass man nicht versucht zu
entziehen zu verbergen dass jetzt
vielleicht rot anläuft manifestiert sich
manifestiert sich der igel
wir kennen sicherlich habe schon seit
der würgereflex das wäre jetzt aber eben
nur eine naturalistische bestimmung des
titels gegen die sich auch schon schüler
bei seiner analyse geschrieben gewendet
hat das ist also nicht die ganze sache
des phänomens wenn wir nur sagen er ist
gleich reaktion auf etwas was wir wieder
ich finden würgereflex vielleicht sogar
noch mehr übergeben und zu wenn das
würde zu kurz greifen
wie lässt sich der ekel von verwandten
emotionen unterscheiden
wir hatten schon ich sagen diskutiert
das könnte man sie noch überlegen wie
verhält sich gelohnt angst das ist auch
noch ein thema was passierte aufkommen
wird weil wir sehen wir weiter den er
kennt nicht als ein biologisches
phänomen analysiert sind als
existenzielles verlieren und auch die
angst wie den folgenden sitzung noch nie
gesehen werden clicker aber auch bei
heiliger die angst ist auch eine emotion
die ganz starke existenzialisten für
ihre theorie genutzt wurde anders gesagt
in der angst zeigt sich besonders unsere
existenz und so eben auch nach seiten
über gleich sehen werden im ekel
also nicht im besitz der ekel kurz
gesagt nach seiner existenziellen
situationen wie für ein besitztum igel
nach nußbaum eine kognitive dienen sie
haben den text gelesen da geht es um
diese kognitiven strukturen dem ekel
angelegt sind nussbaum interpretiert in
ekel nicht so sehr wie sauer existenz
von ufos oder individualistisch
individuum her und seiner existenz
gedacht sondern ihr von einer inter
subjektiven struktur her
vor allem aus der gesichtspunkt des
staates der gesellschaft als ein anderer
fokus auf phänomen der motionen des
nickels dass er ist jetzt der seite ein
existenziell ist wie ein buch entsteht
mit der typischen existenzialisten zwei
filmen und ich sage noch mal ein paar
daten zusammen
er war ein französischer schriftsteller
existenzialisten firmen geld also die
französische philosoph es dadurch
ausgezahlt zumindest zum zwanzigsten
jahrhundert aber auch heute noch dass
sie die grenzen von strikter philosophie
und literatur überschreitet große
philosophischen und philosophen aus
frankreich waren häufig gute
schriftstellerinnen und schriftstellern
simon de wo er ist ein anderes beispiel
und so weiter und so fort
also das ist die in dieser französischen
neueren philosophie der diese grenzen
überschritten
da hat eben auch wichtige bücher
geschrieben und diese schrift der ekel
aus der wir heute einen zentralen aus
genießen ist ebenso wohl ein
philosophisches werk als auch ein
literarisches werk von weltrang weil
zahlte darin seine existenzialistische
philosophie gegründet oder entwickelt
zahlte aber nicht die erste
existenzialisten immer die frage wo ist
meine existenz
viele sagen mir gekommen sei der erste
gewesen manche gehen soweit und sagen
sogar schelling friedrich wilhelm joseph
schelling sei der erste gewesen
zumindest eine späte schelling der auch
die existenz ins zentrum gerückt
heiliger ist sicherlich auch eine
existenz finden soll
diese philosophischen hauptwerk was er
geschrieben hat mit dem tisch muttersein
und hast nichts wenn man zusätzlich
entwickelte theorie die existentiellen
freiheit die im wesentlichen von der
bedeutung die negativität ausgeht
das ist sein hauptwerk und wir werden
wahrscheinlich daraus etwas lesen wenn
es in einer der nächsten sitzung um das
phänomen des hasses gibt mainzer in
dieser schrift interessantes dazu zu
sagen hat
so jetzt geben aber mit dem reinen diese
schrift der ekel ich lese auf deutsch
dann könnte es auch französisch lesen
aber das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu
schwierig als er sagte dass es dieses
dass ich diesen ich erzähler und diese
um hand sagt der ekel hat mich seit der
es wieder nicht losgelassen und ich
glaube nicht dass er mich bald loslassen
wird aber ich leide ihn nicht mehr
das ist keine krankheit mehrkampf nur
über geld anfallen
ich bin es selbst alles und ich war
gerade im park die wurzel des
kastanienbaum bohrte sich in die erde
genau unter einer bank ich erinnerte
mich nicht mehr dass es eine wurzel bat
werte waren und mit ihnen die bedeutung
der dinge ihre verwendung sind die
schwachen markierungen die die menschen
auf ihrer oberfläche eingezeichnet habe
ich sah es da etwas krumm den kopf
gesenkt allein dieser schwarzen und
knoten ganzen gang hohem masse gegenüber
die mir angst macht soll das haben wir
ja schon verschiedene wichtige wichtige
begriffe also der ecke ist keine
krankheit kein vorher übergehende anfang
und könnte auch interpretieren werden
ist kein effekt da das wäre ja etwas
vorübergehendes an der ecke ist etwas
permanentes etwas was ich stärker
ausdehnt das ist ein charakteristikum
von emotionen die ich sie definiere und
er geht sogar soweit und seit ich bin er
selbst also ich bin der regel selbst das
wiederum bestätigt meine theorie dass
die emotionen und es ganz erfüllt nicht
nur etwas äußerliches nie ein gefühl ich
habe hunger oder geschwärzt sind
emotionen
in der emotion kommen wir als subjekte
ganz zu tragen ganz zugeht wir sind ganz
erfüllt also ich bin selbst soll und
jetzt kommt eine sehr berühmte
existenzialistische quittung der
kastanienbaum und seine wurzeln und er
nimmt die wurzel nicht mehr begrifflich
nicht mehr sprachen sondern
unmittelbaren auf eine ganz besondere
weise
und zwar so dass er angst bekommt als
ekel und angst stehen hier auch nach
seiner emotionalen einer sehr engen
beziehung wir sehen wir schon warum
sollten wir uns denn vor einer wurzel
eines chors kastanienbaum häkeln wenn
sie mal eine umfrage machen in einem
park und dann zeigen sie den menschen
geben umhergehen diese eine wurzel eines
kastanien bei uns vielleicht sogar des
großen alten mächtigen dann wird
bestimmt niemand sagen dass das ekel
erregt ist wenn sie dann erst die
mülheimer ist in dem sich vielleicht
schmeißfliegen des hinten weil sich da
irgendwie fleisch befindet was schon zum
verrottet ist dann wohl schon ihr also
sie sehen sagte hat hier bin er vom
titel spricht nicht diesen körperlichen
ekel im sinne sondern ein ekel den mann
existenziellen ekel nennen könnte oder
auch metaphysischen ekeln metaphysisch
deswegen weil es ihm um die eigene
existenz jährige ganzheit geht weiter
sagt jetzt dieser erzähle das hat mir
den atem geraubt nie von diesen letzten
tagen hatte ich geahnt was das heißt
existieren
ich war wie die anderen wie jene die am
meer entlang spazieren in ihre
führungsgruppe
ich sagte ich sie das meer ist grün
diese weise punkt da oben das ist eine
möwe aber ich fühlte nicht dass das
existiert dass die möwe eine
existierende event war gewöhnlich
verbringt sich die existenz sie ist da
um uns in uns ist wie man kann keine
zwei worte sagen
wenn wir von ihr zu sprechen und letzten
endes wird man sie nicht wenn ich
glaubte zu denken dachte ich im grunde
gar nichts bekommen verlieren oder ich
hatte gerade nur ein wort im kopf das
wort sein oder aber ich dachte ich soll
ich sagen
alle hier geht es jetzt ganz rund um den
begriff der existenz ich habe in der
letzten semester dazu ein seminar
gemacht oben rechts wieder der duell ist
dann nachher auf youtube wo es um die
existenz gehen der existenz begriff ist
dann schwierig zugestimmt existenz oder
das etwas existiert ist nicht zu
verstehen er eine eigenschaft
also wenn ich sagen ich existiere oder
der stein existiert ist es etwas anders
zu sagen also wenn ich sage ich bin
heute müde oder der stein ist grau
existent ist wie man kann sagt kein
reales prädikat wir sagen wenn wir sagen
dass die existiert nichts inhaltliches
über das ding haus
wir sagen nur aus etwas das das gesamte
betrifft wir setzen das team als ganzes
aber dass existieren das ding ist keine
eigenschaft dann ist es gewissermaßen
der rahmen in dem sich das ding befindet
ergebnis gesetzt kann spielt von der
position ist jetzt könnten ja auch sein
dass sie existiert nicht oder das ding
ist möglich wir sind modalitäten und
modalitäten sind zu unterscheiden von
eigenschaften
ok dann machte es diesen riesigen topf
auf und die existenz betrifft weiter
sagt dass er das erzählt ich dachte die
zugehörigkeit ich sagte mir dass das
meer zum klasse denken gegenständen
wirtschaft modern können eine der
eigenschaften des meeres war sogar wenn
ich die dinge anzahl war ich einen weit
davon entfernt zu denken dass existieren
sie waren für mich nur den chor nahmen
sie in meine hände sie diente mir als
werkzeug
ich zeige widerstände voraus aber das
alles spielte sich an der oberfläche ab
wenn man mich gefragt hätte was die
existenz hätte ich gut und glauben
genannt wurde dass das nicht zahlen
nichts weiter als eine leere form die
von außen zu den dingen hinzutreten oder
etwas an ihrer ohne etwas an ihrer natur
zu
und dann plötzlich auf einmal bares tag
es war klar dass licht die existenz
hatte sich plötzlich enthüllt sie hatte
ihre harmlosigkeit einer abstrakten
kategorie verloren sie war der
eigentliche teil der dinge
diese wurzel war in existenz ein
geknetet oder vielmehr die wurzel das
gitter des parks die bank das sperrige
gras des rasens das alles verschwunden
die vielfalt der dinge ihre
individualität waren nur scheinfirmen
diese firma geschmolzen zurückblieb
monströse und farbiger maßen
ungeordneten hat von einer
erschreckenden und obszönen markt soll
jetzt haben wir hier also ein ganz
großes fass aufgemacht wird es geht um
die existenz ich habe davor gesagt bevor
regentag existenz nach kant kein reales
prädikat kein nachhaltiges prädikat und
das scheint mir im ersten satz ich auch
das sagen dass er erst im wird schon
verfallen war zu glauben dass das eine
eigenschaft existenz der vertreten
würden
dann aber kommt er zu der erkenntnis
dass existenz nicht nur eine wir hier
sagt abstrakte kategorie ist wie sie im
kant angesehen hatte und die ganze
tradition davor sind das existenz
eigentlich etwas ist was gefährlich es
ist nicht harmlos es ist etwas was uns
angst macht und etwas vor denen wir
erschrecken und was letztendlich auch
amorph ist formlos monströs ein monster
die existenz ist etwas was ihn
überwältigt und wo unsere begriffe
versagen
hier haben wir jetzt hier einen schönen
bezug zur scham die obszöne nacktheit
ist ja ein inferno man sich schämt und
ja mal eben einen bezug das was die
existenz heimlich bedeutet ist etwas wo
wir scharf in angst empfinden und jetzt
geht er sogar so weit wie kann also
nichts körperliches keine körperlichen
reaktion
eine wie schüler sagen würde ein
geistiges gefühle
weiter jetzt dieser erzähler die hüte
der mich die geringste bewegung zu
machen habe ich brauche mich nicht zu
hören
um hinter den bäumen die blauen sollen
und in der therme fall des
musikpavillons zu sehen und die weleda
mitten in einer gruppe von robert a alle
diese gegenstände wie soll ich sagen sie
belästigt ich hätte gewünscht sie würden
weniger stark existieren auf trockenere
abstraktere weise mit mir zurückhaltend
der kastanien warum drängt er sich gegen
meine augen grüner brand bedeckte ihn
bis in halverde die rinde schwarzem
aufgebunden steht aus gekochtem leder
das sei das leise plätschern des
marktbrunnens sicher den mann und
nistete sich dort ein erfüllte sich mit
der zeit eine nasenlöcher gewinn über
für einen grünen und vor allen dingen
gaben sich sanfte zärtliche existenzen
wie jene erwarteten frauen die sich dem
lachen hingeben und mit voller stimme
sagen lachen ist gesund sie breiteten
sich voneinander aus sie machten sich
das abscheuliche geständnis ihre
existenz hier ist jetzt ziemlich konkret
bringt er jetzt ganz ganz nah und
lebensweltlich verständliche
beschreibungen dieses deckels hier ist
sogar so etwas wie ein trauriger gerupft
also hier werde jetzt schon fast
körperlich wenn es um existenzielle geht
also die existenz ist nichts
zurückhaltend ist auch schon gar nichts
kein formales logisches liefern kann
sondern die existenz drängt sich uns auf
ihr hier seid getränkt ist wie die augen
der existenz die ergreift uns
gewissermaßen und das kann uns angst
nahm ich begriff dass es keine mittig
zwischen der nichtexistenz um diese
überschäumenden füllen wenn man
existierte musste man bis dahin
existieren bis zum verschimmeln zur
aufgedunsen hyde zu obszönität in einer
anderen welt bewahren die kreisen
in ihre reihen und streng gegen aber die
existenz seien nach gegen bäume
nächtliche zahlen das glücklich
entwickelt anspringt unsleben den
gerüchten kleine werbe nebel die der
kalten luft schwebend ein hotel gemeinde
auf eine anvertraute dieses ganze bösen
dieses ganze betrauen zusammengenommen
wohnt einzigen die komischen an
jetzt wird plötzlich gibt es eine
wendung geht es nicht mehr so sehr die
angst die reaktion sondern das komisch
und jetzt kommen wir immer mehr schritte
schritt zu dem was ich sagen möchte
nämlich das absurde also die existenz
ist nichts was uns angst machen sollte
nichts vielleicht aufhören soll sondern
etwas was absurd ist und das für direkt
ins zentrum seiner existenz sophie hier
bringt er jetzt immer noch solche
konnotationen verschimmeln
aufgeschlossenheit obszönitäten das sind
phänomene wo wir körperlich gegenwind
lenkt sie transit
es ist etwas weisen dann brot und wird
sich merken sie das boot ist vollkommen
verschimmeltes haben es nicht gesehen
weil es internet verschwindet war dann
haben sie eine körperliche reaktion also
hier bringt er wieder die konkreten
momente dieses körperliche nichols in
seine theorie des existentiellen das
wort absurdität entsteht jetzt unter
meiner feder vor in dem park habe ich es
nicht gefunden
aber ich suchte es auch nicht ich
brauchte es nicht ich dachte ohne worte
über den dingen mit denen mit denen die
aktualität das war keine gegen den kopf
keinen einfluss sondern diese lange
schlange zum einlösen diese holzstangen
schlange oder kralle oder wurzel oder
klauen was auch immer ohne etwas
deutlich zu formulieren begriff ich dass
nicht den schlüssel der existenz den
schlüssel meines enkels meines eigenen
lebens gefunden hat
tatsächlich geht alles dass ich
anschließend erfassen konnte auf diese
fundamentale absolut zurück absolut wie
dein wort ich schlage würde um dort ein
paar gehörte ich das ding aber ich
möchte hier die absolutheit
diese absurdität festhalten
hier finde ich jetzt interessant und
bezog dass er hier von dieser wurzel
dieses kastanienbaum sni von einer toten
schlange spricht das nicht auf und das
würde uns natürlich hin zum sündenfall
adam und eva wo auch ein baum vorkommen
wo auch eine schlange vorkommen würden
auch die scham und vielleicht auch die
ekel vorkommt das scheint er seine
referenz darauf zu sein
wichtig ist jetzt hier dass er den ekel
und die existenz mit absurdität fast und
der absurdität
das war jetzt zahlen wir können nachher
noch genauer darüber diskutieren wie wir
nägel verstehen müssen ob es so etwas
auch in unserem alltag gibt oder ob es
ein ganz spezieller ich will jetzt geht
es ein bisschen näher die gegenwart mit
dieser dame hier mit marga nußbaum die
1947 geboren ist und noch sehr rege ist
sie ist eine us amerikanische
philosophin und professorin an der
university of chicago ich hab sie dort
auch mein einer vorlesung kennen gelernt
und was ihr beeindruckt von ihrer
engagierten art zu philosophieren sie
war auch mal an der lmu münchen hat der
glaube ist auch mein und meisterkursen
workshop gegeben
sie forscht vor allem zur
rechtsphilosophie und ethik und wichtig
ist da sich dabei an der antiken
philosophie orientiert vor allem
aristoteles und dass sie immer von einer
in das objekt even warte aus die
phänomene betrachtet anders als die in
den calis tisch konkret existenz wieder
losgeht nußbaum gesellschafts
philosophisch an die verschiedenen
phänomene ran und eben auch anders
phänomen des titels und wir lesen jetzt
eben einen kurzen auszug aus ihrem text
den ich ihnen geschickt hat und zwar
englisch in discuss discover studierende
special bisherige wolfgang baade die
reactions system berlin
offen hälften marc badertscher
striptease ins classic edition ist damit
jetzt classics kimmons wallace and
optics fußballfans teams lust an lassen
nannte less important research
technologies von losen has made
intelligent wird dieses gas peter kopp
komplex content mit focus und energie
auch in cooperation of content desk
organisches gastwirt reportern prospekt
auf eur in cooperation of an offense
lautet ihre fans of the continents der
stephen gately contact an acceptance of
nature and food an exakte simulieren in
fried menninghaus biggs auf des
gaspreises auf session ergänzt anders im
internet application auf dem quad closen
dass dennis natur und in münchen optik
ist es kontamination eine distanz von
bisher also wir sehen hier gleich ersten
zitat scheint auf den ersten blick eine
besonders körperliche emotion zu sein
wissen heißt sich auf ein gebäude also
etwas was in uns in unserem haus
sozusagen vor sich geht außer vehicle
wie zu übergeben unser alter ekel
impliziert lesen sagt starke körperliche
reaktionen und der besondere spezielle
ausdruck von egl ist sicherlich über
sich übergeben
und jetzt bezieht sich auf
technologischen forschung die eben
stinkt stark macht dass ich einen
komplexen kognitiven gehalt hat und zwar
geht es um die idee etwas was uns
vergiftet oder etwas ja kontaminiert das
aufzunehmen
sie sagt es geht jetzt nicht generell
ehrlich nicht generell um irgendwelche
dinge wie jetzt also irgendwie
verschimmeltes brot oder in flaschen
also so dass konkretes denn es geht ganz
allgemein um etwas was
uns vergiftet was uns schadet und was
wir praktisch aufnehmen was in uns
bleibt und sich dann da irgendwie
verbreiten das ist diese grundstruktur
des ekels und jetzt kann man natürlich
so was auch sozialphilosophen
interpretieren weiter geht's rosing das
display des castrol heft allerlei
evolution der ebase infekt akzeptables
argumente des gastes oder jennifer
fraczek dzemaili aufwand ins kloster
connected das tram negativ sense
experience die chance dass das ding von
bloss des taser negativ merkten mode
page sensor effects ender sense of the
danger rejection modernisiert so kann
sie dieses gast des nationaldichters die
künstler james mehr
jetzt liegt's different des kastrations
depending on szabics konzept also was
jetzt hier zeigt ist mit rosen dieser
psychologen dass nicht nur das ist also
etwas was uns nicht schmeckt sondern
dass es immer um eine sozial induzierte
konnotation geht die wir mit diesem
jeweiligen geschmack oder geruch
verbinden also die reaktion des
kastrations die hängen ab von der
konzeption von dem begriff welches sich
das objekt von einem bestimmt objekt
macht das heißt sie argumentiert
letztendlich für die relativität mit
frohsinn relativität vielleicht auch
soziale bedingtheit von ikea ist des
gastes sehen er ist präsident des eigens
gp seines maschen und tollerei mit
solange sbb investiert dass das ding
allerdings anders so toleriert wird wie
in jested die taxifahrt häusern des
marsches dieses casting strangers
casting other people with just do it
still alive kaputtes menning aktiven
fußballer in corpore jeans ein festival
plastikkarte wurde ihm andere gäste in
das abschiedsfest also die macht im bund
stark dass angel also die gefahr dass
das nichts ist was den ekel ausmacht
also wir haben nicht deswegen ekel vor
etwas weil das uns gefährlich ist die
bringt ja als beispiel wir können eine
kakerlake runterschlucken und sie wieder
ausschalten
selbst wenn sie völlig hygienischen und
selbst das obwohl sie hier keine gefahr
das wäre
sterile nicht gefährlich selbst allein
der gedanke sie runterzuschlucken und
verdammt auszusteigen würde uns verträge
erfüllen zumindest jetzt wir die wir
eben kakerlaken in einem kulturkreis
eben nicht gerne es ich weiß nicht ob es
kultur und gibt die gerne kakerlaken ist
ich weiß einfach nicht aber es hängt ja
ebenfalls immer von dieser auffassung ab
das gastkonzert auf der baar kreises und
prospekte robert x6tence maybe corporate
intl
von männern gemacht ist das per
schlittschuh des casting hast du dieses
elend und ballack so lange es den
science wohin es anwar aufhören bekannt
ist das ding after delhi wie closed beta
des gastes ranking firma glass and which
they can just add water centre de lima
in der ddr schnell konnte auf des gastes
sehr oft nur bekannt baseball
kontaminiert jetzt schon auf das
jobcenter des fensters experiments dann
1000 kollegs indicate that i agieren in
wolfegg sz commodity futures oder space
des displays ja es gibt den spruch du
bist was du isst ich glaube kommt an
ihnen also es geht immer darum um das
was sie ausscheiden das ist dasjenige
maß erlebt und nicht das was in uns
trinkst und das zeigt natürlich dass es
hier mal die relativität ist nie ganz
geht
wir sind jetzt von der präsentation erst
am ende des artikels leiter ich gebe
ausbildung der nächsten sitzung geht es
um die verzweiflung bei schierke kommen
und ich wünsche den zuschauern alles
gute bis zur nächsten sitzung